there's a perfect strategic alignment in
the partnership between CMU and the Tony
Awards because it helps shine a light on
the importance of teachers and how they
go on to inspire students CMU is all
about arts education and the Tony Awards
we're looking for a way to communicate
and continue the conversation about the
importance of arts education in America
so creating the excellence in theatre
education award was really the home run
because we got to do good first of all
we got to recognize an important teacher
and teachers in America that teach the
Arts and that inspired people and
influence to have careers in the arts
and not just on stage but also backstage
as a child growing up in Los Angeles my
mother was a huge proponent of the Arts
and I grew up with theatre being part of
my DNA and my mom took us to shows and
it was part of who I was and who I am
today I didn't have a talent to be
onstage even though I wanted to be and I
didn't know that there were careers you
could have offstage and behind the
scenes I wish I had known at and that's
an important thing as well to help
educate people about professional
development and careers in the theater I
think art education is so fundamental to
overall education and to the overall
makeup of a human being we know from
statistics that kids who have strong
arts education do better in school and
they have better outcomes in life but I
think that it's about humanity it's
about education it's about empathy and
the arts teach and incorporate all of
those aspects into a student's life
there is one teacher that has influenced
my life in the arts and that is mr.
Henry lachey from Emerson junior high in
Los Angeles he was the theater arts
teacher but mr. Lachey was such a
passionate person about his craft and it
was contagious and I realized that that
passion was so important and he taught
me about the feeling of connectivity and
that is the one thing today that when I
go to theater I I kind of get my high
from which is that feeling of being
did connected to the story connected to
the music connected to be a stranger
sitting in the dark next to you and
connected to the actors who are who are
performing on stage so it's that energy
and that connectivity that I think I
learned from mr. Roche
you